do you know who is a a great performer
one of truly the greatest performers of
our age i was reminded of this a couple
of days ago
you know the man president koffe donald
trump he gets up there
he's giving a speech about some
completely unrelated topic and he he
brings up
joe biden's falling off a bicycle in the
most charming hilarious way possible
one of the greatest travesties
of all is to see a person in the white
house who
even after years of political experience
has absolutely no clue
how to be the president of the united
states and i hope he has recovered
because as you know he fell off his
bicycle today
no i'm serious i hope he's okay
fell off a bicycle
i make this pledge to you today i will
never ever ride a bicycle
i love the way he turns it there at the
end
like he's doing a comedy routine like
he's lighting up a cigarette next to his
sword you guys hear about this you guys
hear about the president falls off a
bicycle
yeah yeah no he did he did he fell off a
bicycle and then you you you're waiting
for him if he were just an ordinary
politician
he would do one of two things he would
concern troll and he would get very
somber and serious and say no but really
really i am wishing him he's a good
family man
he's a good
especially the bidens quite a family a
good family man i really we hoped for
his recovery he would do that or he
would get really angry and
self-righteous and indignant and make
some political attack on him but trump
has this show business touch
so he's he lures you in he says yeah he
fell off a bicycle he saw that no he did
he did i hope he's okay i hope he's okay
and then he he turns it and makes a
self-effacing joke he's not even
boasting he's not bragging he's not
blowing himself up
he's making a joke about himself because
i'm never going to ride a bicycle you
look at me do i look like the kind of
guy who's going to ride a bicycle this
is something people never got about
trump they all they would see is the
bragging and the boastfulness and the
gold and everything and they think that
the guy's a total egomaniac and a
narcissist that's not quite true
yes he puts his names on the buildings
yes he refers to himself in the third
person but he does have a self-awareness
he would frequently make jokes at his
own expense
one time he was asked about if he would
have a beer and donald trump doesn't
drink and he said me no i'm not i think
i might be the only president who can
say he's never had a beer it's probably
the only good thing you can say about me
he's making a joke that he's got these
sorts of other vices but but he doesn't
drink look at me do you he was asked
once do you are you gonna get a pet in
the white house you're gonna get a dog
and he said no they're all telling me i
need to get a dog to be more likable and
you know that's just what the
president's doing i don't know i don't
think it's me i don't think it's really
me and it's it's not it was not really
him and no you can't picture donald
trump riding a bicycle
these little moments
do give me some pause for
2024. right now ron desantis is getting
a ton of play people are talking about
him as the potential nominee the guy's
amazing i don't i don't have a negative
thing in the world to say about ron
desantis he's a he's the greatest
governor in the country he might be the
greatest governor of a state that i have
seen in my lifetime he's doing a great
job so
there's no wonder that he's getting a
lot of presidential talk
some other people are getting
presidential talk too pompeo is getting
some senator cruz is getting some nikki
haley was getting some i don't know that
she totally is anymore
there are other people who
who are out there as potential nominees
you can tell there are a lot of other
governors and a lot of other senators
who are trying to run for that as well
my hesitation on just saying okay
trump's old news let's move on is just
while all of us who are paying a lot of
close attention to politics while all of
us
might love this governor or that senator
or this former cabinet official and
we're really tuned in we say well here
are all the reasons why so-and-so would
be a much better president than trump
while we're doing that
are we in our own little bubble here do
those other candidates do they have the
ability to reach as many people who
maybe aren't totally tuned into politics
who maybe don't follow all the latest
trends on twitter or whatever
can they reach people as effectively as
trump i don't know this is a totally
open question right now and trump does
come with a lot of baggage and i'm not
convinced that
whether because of his own faults or
because of the system that is completely
rigged against him i'm not sure that
donald trump will be allowed to be
president again
i'm not it's a totally open question but
it is something seriously to consider
the
trump has gifts
that are not
that are not so easily quantified
as some other politicians he's got he's
got aspects to him that are just sort of
ineffable that are just you don't you
don't factor them in as much but a
little joke like that the ability to
rile up a gigantic crowd the the star
power that the guy comes with
is valuable now all of that said
desantis
is not only beginning to challenge trump
in some places he's beginning to pull
ahead up in new hampshire
ron desantis is is now beating trump in
a presidential poll there's a university
of new hampshire granite state poll
released on wednesday
desantis gets 39 percent
trump gets 37 percent
then pence nine percent and nikki haley
six percent so pence and haley are
very very far behind
uh
but desantis and trump desantis is
leading trump by two points
then they did a general election poll
again in new hampshire
desantis versus biden
the poll says desantis wins by 1.4746
trump versus biden the poll says that
trump loses by seven points biden 50
trump 43.
so what does this tell you
that tells you desantis is in a really
really good position
it tells you desantis is doing all the
right things
and it tells you that if trump does want
to do this again if he's really serious
about running again and he's not just
using this as a promise or threat to
maintain his influence in the gop he's
going to have to start getting
aggressive
relatively quickly
he's going to have to start positioning
himself as the guy right now ron
desantis has relatively low name
recognition
that seems strange to you and i because
if you're listening to this show you of
course know who all the players are you
you know all the potential 2024 nominees
you know the governors you know the
senators but
a lot of people don't and a lot of
people know trump trump's been a
celebrity for 40 years
well that's not going to be true forever
the more desantis or whoever
don't forget these these people can peak
very early too and then new candidates
come up no one would have predicted
trump in 2015 2016. but right now
desantis is the guy so
the more desantis shows of himself
the more likable he's going to be the
more name recognition he's going to get
the firmer he's going to be in those
polls and the craziest part of ron
desantis rise
is
he almost wasn't governor this is
something else that we forget about and
frankly actually trump was important in
helping ron desantis get over the finish
line in florida
desantis only won by 33 000 votes
it was desantis versus andrew gillum it
was desantis versus a guy who shortly
after the election was found in a hotel
passed out with narcotics around him and
a gay hooker passed out on the floor
okay that guy that guy was almost the
governor of florida
ron de santa squeaks by with 33 000
votes he could potentially be
the next republican presidential nominee
he could potentially be the next
president shows you how important those
little votes
can be
i'm glad you like that clip now you know
what you got to do hold up wait no don't
don't move on to the next video you've
got to
subscribe ring that bell ding dong like
let's do it we're coming up on a million
subscribers everybody by the way thank
you for subscribing if you haven't yet
do it send it to your friends we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]